no cost to you.
>> Harris: THE SHERIFF AND
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYEES ARE NOW
SUING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE ACCUSING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF BLOCKING
FEDERAL OFFICIALS FROM DOING
THEIR JOBS.
AND YOU KNOW THE SURGE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ACROSS OUR
BORDER IS SHOWING NO SIGNS OF
SLOWING DOWN.
REPUBLICANS ARE RAILING AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT’S BORDER POLICIES
WHICH ARE JUST A REVERSAL OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAD DONE IN
THE OFFICE.
CONGRESSMAN BOB GOOD WARNS THE
U.S. HAS, QUOTE, NO OPERATIONAL
CONTROL OF THE BORDER AFTER HE
GOT A FIRSTHAND LOOK AT THE
SITUATION.
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ WITH
THIS.
>> RIGHT NOW I THINK THEIR
HANDS ARE TIED BECAUSE THEY’VE
MADE THE PROMISES.
THEY WON’T GO BACK ON THE
PROMISES I DON’T BELIEVE.
SO JOE BIDEN WILL NOT BE
WILLING TO ENFORCE THE BORDER
OR STOP THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
HIS ONLY SOLUTION TO THE BORDER
CRISIS IS LIKE AN OSTRICH STICK
HIS HEAD IN THE SAND AND HOPE
THAT THE MEDIA DOESN’T COVER IT.
>> Harris: REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS OF
ARIZONA, CO-CHAIR OF THE HOUSE
BORDER SECURITY CAUCUS AND ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE JUDICIARY AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE
PROGRAM.
THE IDEA OF STICKING ONE’S HEAD
IN THE SAND.
FIRST OF ALL, TALK TO ME ABOUT
WHAT BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE REFUSING TO
SEE ABOUT THE BORDER CRISIS.
>> THEY’RE NOT SEEING ANYTHING.
THEY DON’T GET THE NUMBERS.
THEY ARE RELEASING PEOPLE INTO
THE COUNTRY JUST ENORMOUS
NUMBERS, 10,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN ALONE RECENTLY
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY.
78,000 CHILDREN UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN HAVE COME TO THE
COUNTRY THIS YEAR.
IT’S FIVE TIMES MORE THAN THE
HIGHEST EVER.
THEY DON’T SEE THE NUMBERS.
THEY DON’T SEE THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS ON THE BORDER.
SO WHEN KAMALA HARRIS, VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS GOES TO
THE BORDER TO EL PASO SHE
DOESN’T GO TO THE AREAS ALONG
THE BORDER HARDEST HIT.
SO THEY DON’T SEE ANYTHING
EXCEPT FOR THEY DON’T WANT TO
BRING THE TRUMP POLICIES BACK
IN.
THEY’RE MISSING, HARRIS,
THEY’RE MISSING THE ENTIRE
PICTURE OF WHAT’S GOING ON ON
THE BORDER IN MY OPINION.
>> Harris: SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE HOUSE,
REPRESENT STEVE SCALISE AND
TONY GONZALEZ LAID OUT A COUPLE
THINGS THE PRESIDENT CAN DO TO
FIGHT THE BORDER CRISIS.
I KNOW HE PUT KAMALA HARRIS IN
CHARGE OF IT.
SINCE NOTHING IS HAPPENING
THERE THE BEST THING THE
PRESIDENT COULD DO ACCORDING TO
THEM RIGHT NOW ARE TO REJECT
TALK OF RESCINDING TITLE 42 OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY ACT,
WHICH ALLOWS BORDER PATROL TO
TURN AWAY ILLEGALS WHO WERE
RECENTLY IN A COUNTRY WITH A
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE.
AND REVERSE HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT STOPS ALL BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION AND REPEALED THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
SCALISE AND GONZALEZ SAY YOU
COULD JUST START THERE.
>> THEY’RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
REMAIN IN MEXICO WORKED.
BUILDING THE FENCE WORKED.
TITLE 42 IS WORKING.
SO THEY NEED TO REINSTATE THOSE
FULLY.
THEY ALSO COULD REINSTATE THE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE STATES OF HONDURAS,
NICARAGUA AND EL SALVADOR.
TAKE AWAY INNOCENTIVES FOR
$1400 FOR EVERY MIGRANT THE
COMES ACROSS THE BORDER.
RHETORIC AND BULLY PULPIT WOULD
WORK.
IF THIS PRESIDENT WOULD SAY
DON’T COME AND ENFORCES THOSE
POLICIES, GUESS WHAT?
THE CARTELS GET THAT.
THEY CONTROL THE BORDER RIGHT
NOW.
AND THEY WOULD SAY OKAY, WE’LL
HAVE TO SLOW IT DOWN OR FIND
SOME OTHER BUSINESS MODEL.
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IT
INDICATES THEY’RE WILLFUL,
HARRIS.
>> Harris: THIS IS GOING TO BE
COSTLY FOR DEMOCRATS.
STEVE HILTON FROM THE NEXT
REVOLUTION ON THE FOX NETWORK.
>> IT’S POSSIBLE THE ISSUE
ITSELF IS VERY POWERFUL AS WE
SAW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
BECAUSE IT SPEAKS TO PEOPLE’S
CONCERNS ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
NOT BEING IN CONTROL OF EVENTS.
SECONDLY, THE CRISIS AT THE
BORDER CAUSED BY BIDEN’S
POLICIES, THAT SPEAKS TO THE
INCOMPETENCE, THE GENERAL
INCOMPETENCE OF THE BIDEN
REGIME.
>> Harris: BASICALLY WHAT STEVE
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN SAYING,
CONGRESSMAN, IS POLITICALLY
THIS WILL START TO REALLY HURT.
BY THEN THE NATION WILL HAVE
BEEN HURT.
>> HE IS RIGHT ON THAT ON TWO
FRONTS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
WE HAVEN’T EVEN TALKED THIS
MORNING ABOUT THE TERRORISTS ON
KNOWN WATCH LISTS THAT COME
ACROSS THE BORDER BUT IT IS
POLITICAL LIABILITY FOR THEM AS
WELL.
RIGHT NOW IT IS ABOVE 60%.
SO AS PEOPLE BECOME MORE AND
MORE AWARE.
THEY HAVE TO BECOME AWARE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE -- WITH
APPREHENSIONS AND GETAWAYS
COMING IN YOU ARE ABOUT A
QUARTER MILLION PEOPLE PER
MONTH OVER THE LAST FOUR MONTHS
THAT ARE COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Harris: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> THAT’S A MILLION PEOPLE,
YEAH.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
THIS.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
REFUSING TO COMMENT ON
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR’S
STANDING BY HER COMPARISON OF
THE U.S. AND ISRAEL TO TERROR
GROUPS LIKE HAMAS AND THE
TALIBAN.
THIS WEEK OMAR TOOK AIM AT HER
JEWISH DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
SAYING THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
PARTNERS IN JUSTICE.
AND WHEN SHE WAS ASKED ABOUT
THOSE REMARKS YESTERDAY, THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE CUT THE
REPORTER OFF MID QUESTION.
WATCH.
>> BASICALLY WE HEARD THIS WEEK
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR.
>> LET’S STAY WITH THIS AND
I’LL ANSWER THAT LATER.
>> Harris: SHE AND BIDEN HAVE
THAT IN COMMON.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAUGHT HIS
NEWS CONFERENCE EARLIER.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE A LOT OF NEWS
GO BACK AND FORTH EARLIER WITH
BIDEN.
HE WAS CUTTING QUESTIONS OFF
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
HOW CAN THEY HOLD ILHAN OMAR
ACCOUNTABLE IF THE SPEAKER
WON’T EVEN LET YOU ASK ABOUT IT?
>> THE MEDIA IS ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS.
THEY WON’T ANSWER THEM
APPARENTLY.
IT IS CONSISTENT.
THIS IS NOT LIKE A ONE-OFF
STATEMENT BY REPRESENTATIVE
OMAR.
THIS IS A HISTORY AND PATTERN.
I TYPICALLY WILL FORGIVE
SOMEBODY WHO MAKES A STATEMENT
THAT’S INAPPROPRIATE ONE TIME.
YOU LOOK AT IT, YOU COULD GET
FLUSTERED AND SAY SOMETHING YOU
SHOULDN’T SAY BUT THIS IS A
PATTERN.
AND THE DEMOCRATS, SPEAKER
PELOSI, HAS ALLOWED IT TO GO ON
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
AND --
>> Harris: WHY?
, DO YOU KNOW?
>> MY GUESS IS THAT HER POWER
MARGIN IS SO THIN SHE CAN’T
AFFORD TO LOSE ANYBODY IN ORDER
TO REMAIN THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
IF THAT’S THE CASE THAT’S AN
UNPRINCIPLED -- I TAKE A
CYNICAL VIEW OF THINGS BUT I
THINK THAT’S THE WAY IT IS.
>> Harris: IMAGINE HOW THIN
THAT POWER MARGIN WILL BE AS WE
GET CLOSER TO 2022 AND YOU SEE
PEOPLE LISTENING MORE TO
REPUBLICANS ABOUT DON’T DEFUND
THE COPS AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
PEOPLE SAY ARE ON TOP OF THEIR
LIST OF THINGS THEY CARE ABOUT.
CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGGS FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF MY HOME OF